[Music]
the jay sisters are back this is
overwhelming
on Thursday the Jonas Brothers dropped
their new signal and music video for
what a man gotta do recreating some
classic rom-com moments with help of
their real-life leading ladies yep
Priyanka Chopra sophie Turner and
Danielle Jonas all got in on the fun and
we mean fun chewing china be wasting
time on stupid people in Japan Nick
showed off a whole lot of man thigh
channeling his inner Tom Cruise a la
risky business
yeah that seemed you know the one where
tom is dancing around his house rocking
nothing but sucks a button-down collared
shirt and shades not bad Nick
he had that pantsless run and slide on
lock if people can find something to say
about Nick's body god help us as for
Nick's wife Priyanka there she is
wearing a white shirt and jeans looking
at her man with those you're totally
ridiculous but also adorable eyes before
she took the floor in the same sexy
nothing but a t-shirt and socks look
okay no offense Nick but your wife looks
way hotter in this outfit anyway moving
it along what a man gotta do Joe and his
wife Sophie work to the high school
dance floor giving us major hand jive
grease vibes
to be that way
Joe and Sofie actually make a really
believable Danny in Sandy I mean Joe
totally mailed John Travolta's look pink
shirt and all and those moves not
exactly the same but pretty damn close
then of course there's Kevin and his
wifey Danielle who recreated an iconic
scene from say anything
[Music]
Kevin went full-blown John Cusack
standing in a beige trench coat outside
Danielle's window with a boombox over
his head but when the boom box doesn't
work because let's be real it's 2020 and
boom boxes are relics he swaps it out
for his iPhone okay now here's where
things get weird
at the end of the video Joe and Kevin
both rock their itty bitty undies - but
why so much man thigh thankfully they
redeem themselves with a big dance floor
finish and an epic blooper reel
[Music]
of course this isn't the first time the
Jay sisters have starred in a Joe Broz
music video
they went front and center for the
group's comeback single sucker back when
the video dropped et spoke with Anthony
Mandler who directed the sucker music
video and he spilled some
behind-the-scenes secrets though guys
are happy to be part of it great people
and although all the Y's were amazing
and the whole thing was exciting I the
only way we kept his secrets that we did
it very quickly I think we shot two
weeks ago and and I'm they contacted me
a week earlier so the whole thing was
about three weeks which is this sized
project and the amount of people of
where we were you know obviously always
worried about paparazzi and leaks and
whatnot you had none of those issues at
all it's a miracle and no one knew but
certainly the effect has been as big as
I've ever seen in my career
the Jonas Brothers keep raising the bar
with these music videos and I'm here for
it of course you can count on et to
bring you all the latest on these guys
and the Jay sisters so make sure to keep
it locked right here until next time I'm
Haley Stephens see you soon
[Music]